[Music]
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today one of
the things we've discovered at Ramsey
years ago that has set us apart from the
financial professional Financial
goobers um is that we figured out
personal finances 80%
Behavior it's only 20% head knowledge
the mathematics of becoming wealthy are
really about the sixth grade level if
you can do multiplication you can
understand compound interest
and so it it's it's it's within your
grasp you don't have to be a uh PhD in
mathematics to do it but the problem
with understanding that personal finance
is 80% behavior is then you have to
think okay what affects behavior and
what you're going to always see woven
through this show and you've seen it in
the last few callers here and even the
emailer is behavior is all about
relationships it's not all about it but
I mean it's one of the relationships
your marriage relationship your kids
your your grandmother wants to give you
a secret gift not that your cousins
don't know about I mean see none of this
has anything to do with math if you're
just doing math it's like $30,000 free
dollars yes right right Check Yes George
Straight would yeah want you to do there
you go check yes or I mean you know
mutual funds averaging 11.8% rate of
return Check Yes boom just like that you
don't have you don't have to think about
this stuff it's just a math answer
instantly the problem is is that it's
not a math answer you have to anticipate
and consider the relational the
spiritual the emotional psychological
any components of behavior if you don't
consider those considering this whole
thing is 80% behavior in other words the
number one thing that screws up people's
ability to build wealth is
their friends and family or them or your
personal Behavior yeah it's you it's not
your lack of knowledge of some
sophisticated Financial product it's not
that you don't know the secrets of the
rich it's your freaking dysfunctional
family that put the fun and
dysfunctional and that and now you're
living out of that and that screws up
your wealth building more than anything
else yeah well I mean it's it's the
perspective you have to have in putting
money in its proper place in your life
and when you realize that money is a
tool as I say on my to create a life you
love money is the is the tool for it
right but it's your life your life
surrounds it or it surrounds your life
I'm like it is the thing that touches
every area of your life and when you
just try to do math you're trying to
make it its own thing over here and it's
not it is it is built into everything
it's built into soccer registrations if
you have the money to do soccer for your
kids for the fall it has to do with
family trips just happened it yeah it
has to it flows through life it's it's
the thing the currency we have to have
to live our life it's not just the
numbers and so when you realize that you
realize wow it does touch every area of
our life and yeah and the problem with
it is it's us we say that all the time
it's the guy in the mirror you shave
with is what you say yep that's exactly
right and Larry brette used to say that
money problems are not the problem
they're the symptom yep of something
else that's going on in your life and so
including when I went broke it was not
because there was some colossal
conspiracy against Dave it's because
Dave signed up for a first class ticket
on the stupid ship and went on the
entire cruise there's no question I mean
stopped every port every port on the
stupid ship and said yes I you know
that's it we were there baby and and so
but it was the behaviors that put me
there that left me open to and and the
character flaws for that matter not not
of lack of Integrity or something but
other things say and which Jade wara
just wrote a book on this but your
mindset too right you believed a certain
way of dealing with money you belied
certain principles were going to get you
rich you believe this way and so also
shifting your mindset and learning new
ways to handle your money though that
that head knowledge is important that
20% of learning what to do with your
money is still key but why you do what
you do with money is important too which
is the behavior yeah it it's and that's
one of the reasons I get so uh come down
so hard on these people that are hope
Steelers out there running around going
well you just can't in America today
it's there's systemic this and systemic
that well there is there's also systemic
success it's everywhere around you look
there's systemic wealth building it
happens everywhere and it's the people
that plug into that system y instead of
believing your system of
socialism uh Anarchy is going to solve
the problem which is a bunch of crap
it's just you're frustrated and you feel
stuck and you lost your hope but don't
spread that stuff and tell well you
can't it's impossible for the Gen Z
they're very frustrated because they
can't be a millionaire yes they can be a
millionaire they be a millionaire by the
freaking time they're 30 if they get
their crap together hey I just was with
a girl she's uh 15 years old 15 years
old yep opened up a Roth IRA when she
was like 10 years old cuz she started
working in her dad's company and she
started doing all this and she did the
calculation she told me she'll be a
millionaire by
30 so I was like well there you go now
she had Parents who were teaching her
and helping her and encouraging this
right so she's in an environment yeah
that's beautiful but I'm like and so
when she goes into some leftist
communist College professor's economics
class who says you can't do this stuff
she's going to hold up her little Roth
IRA and go or you know ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding or scrolling Tik Tok
and we we played a Tik Tok video here
last week of a guy and he's like the
middle class you have to make $120,000
to be middle class oh what a and
he walked through all the numbers you
know and some of you like but you know
he had like well you only have $625 left
I don't I don't know and we were like oh
my gosh what if you invested that right
like it's the hopes it's the attitude
it's the attitude behind it so I think
you're exactly right when you don't
believe you can and when you teach other
people that they can't that puts you in
the evil bucket The Hope Stealers are
evil when you steal people's hope that's
what you're doing now I I I've been
accused of being a dream killer because
people call up with bizarre crap and I
tell them not to do it uh that's not a
dream killer that is a nightmare
avoidance instructor yeah that's
different than killing a dream I'm
killing a nightmare so but but there's a
difference in that there's instead of
saying no matter what you do you're
screwed that's right that's right and
and you're not you're not you don't have
to drive that car you don't have to wear
that shirt you don't have to carry that
purse you don't have to wear those shoes
you do not have to do any of that to be
a quality human and to build wealth you
can do as a matter of fact the less of a
bunch of that stuff I just listed you do
the faster you're going to build wealth
cuz all of those things are
consumption and so you know this this
idea that uh uh you can get away
from you can
ignore your personal character you can
ignore toxic relationships toxic work
environments and still get ahead that
you can ignore the fact that your spouse
is spending money faster than you can
make it that's a relationship breakdown
you cannot ignore those things we did
not interview a single millionaire that
said I became a millionaire in spite of
my
spouse you know yeah I I you know I did
did talk to one guy he said I lost 110
PBS I divorced her but oh my gosh fix
that but I oh my gosh but he did you she
lost you can't carry I know but she you
can't carry them into it you can't carry
them into that's right that's right you
got they everybody's got to be working
together these are things we know and
and and again that's not a hope stealer
comment that's a that's to me that's the
challenge that if you find yourself in a
situation and you are married and you
guys are on completely separate pages
let this be a challenge to say hey get
on the same page not just to build
wealth but your quality of your
relationships again money is just a tool
your the quality of the relationship
will be better like all of this fits
together and so it is it's it's oh it's
so crucial it's so crucial if you don't
get the the elements of behavior going
you there is not a product
there's not a mutual fund there's not a
technique there's not a a Tik Tock video
that's going to help you if you don't
get the thing the elements of behavior
your spiritual walk your emotional and
psychological Health your ability to set
boundaries with toxic people in and
around you including your family your
quality of your marriage the unity the
fact that we're in lock step and both
working towards a high definition
Vision dream that we want to live
together you cannot avoid that stuff as
a matter of fact if you do all of that
stuff and do some of the math wrong
you'll still be okay but you can't do
the math all right and do all that wrong
and make it it won't work create your
free every doll budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life